this is also 1 good choice
because we have great ambitions in our beautiful province
we have to build many houses
building new roads
and then you have to tackle the nitrogen problem
here is again
the agricultural sector opposed to housing
while has already been debunked several times
today also by pointer caro ncrv
has been debunked several times
that housing
not stopped by the nitrogen problem
but due to the fact that there are too few permits
have been requested
due to the high interest rate and the high land price
and the fact that investors are real estate investors too
keeping the money in the bank right now
also with a view to the even more sustainable
rules for housing
that is the reason
there should be no fairytales here
because I hear it here and the VVD say
and I hear this 6 hours has put it right
madam of the class
you said it
it is